it started out so John Keller will tell
us about solving of applause as a stone
sensor I mean saltings spawns daringly
dominate the linear systems is the sort
of like one of the one of the problems
you know that like you know like the CPU
time in the world is gonna shoot someone
told me a long time ago day in a in
applied domain whenever anyone is
solving a video system it's actually
just about lost in the new system any
case I then took the fuel economy by an
amazing transformation in the the past
10 or 15 years I just went it it looks
like it can't get any more amazing it
does so John will fill us in on the
background in the state of the art in
the sequel to the next to thank you
thank you so today I'm going to start
and tomorrow will be two more lectures
and they're going to be broadly about
solving laplacian systems and electrical
flows really won't surface today but
they'll sort of acing the next two
lectures and before i start i think i'm
going to take the chance to get a little
bit of a higher high level picture so
before they even get to laplacian
systems i kind of want to say at least
why I got into this general direction
and then i'll keep my pontificating
brief and i'll get the actual math
fairly quickly so the very high level
picture but i'm interested in here is
really what i think is kind of incipient
convergence between graph algorithms and
numerical scientific computing so if you
kind of a look at the last I'm making up
words sometime what we define them so i
graph algorithms you know questions
about flows and paths and cuts and we'll
talk and sort of if you look at the main
fast algorithms for a lot of these
problems as of fairly recently the best
algorithms for almost all the problems
that we know we're very much discrete
combinatorial algorithms path by pat's
low by flo edge by edge kind of kind of
approaches
and then it'd be kind of flip over the
numerical scientific computing side a
lot of the questions and algorithms tend
to be very much continuous they ask
about matrices and computational linear
algebra and differential equations and
for those a lot of the techniques
potentially all the techniques that are
used are very strongly continuous
numerical techniques and what's happened
very recently is well let's happened
less recently with discipline some sort
of diverged and from my perspective I
think that they should reconvert and in
the last maybe decade or so what become
clear is that they've been facing very
similar challenges on a fairly concrete
level like that's a story about a high
level of we need to solve big finish but
on a low level of there's actually is
very deep mathematical connections
between a lot of the core objects that
one studies in the two fields and what's
been emerging is the hope of using
techniques from one of these fields to
help the other and hopefully letting
them sort of rican verge so if I were to
kind of start off I guess it's good to
start public recorded lectures by making
sort of overly aggressive assertions and
so my kind of broad vision here is I
think that there should be a sort of
convergence of graph algorithms in
numerical scientific computing hopefully
speeding up things on both sides and if
you put my kind of high-level goal here
it would be too I think where this will
be in a small number of years hopefully
and but Alexander will talk more about
tamam tomorrow is that I think these
connections will hopefully eventually
lead to a good chunk of the algorithmic
problems on both sides being solvable
nearly linear time so that's the sort of
aggressive high-level goal it's take
your favorite graph algorithms or your
favorite numerical linear algebra
problems and it should come with sort of
the caveat that on the scientific
computing side I don't mean solving
general in your systems I mean solving
ones that actually exist so once that
sort of show up in practice which are
very structured and my hi Lola bowl of
this for me at least is that yet sort of
the main questions on both sides to be
an early look at your time and as a
field making theory of computing
community in the last maybe ten years
you've made a lot of progress on that
and what I'm going to talk about in
these lectures is one facet of this so
I'm going to scrap one Stan Shih ation
of this vision that I think has been a
proof of concept that this actually
plausibly could go somewhere and that's
also how to solve a Faustian linear
systems so linear systems where the
matrix you're using is a graph laplacian
and i'll stop show to solve those in
nearly linear time okay so I'm going to
give a very brief why South laplacian
systems all I guess James kind of
covered it for me broadly they appear a
lot they've appeared in scientific
computing is one of the kind of core
objects that one studies from finite
element settings they also show up for
things will actually exploit their very
strongly connected to the behavior of
electrical circuits and they've also had
a lot of applications in a whole bunch
of other fields in machine learning and
random processes and image processing
data etc etc add another kind of thing
that's been starting to emerge recently
has been that some of the algorithmic
problems on the ground side that we want
we really don't want to solve linear
systems necessarily don't want to solve
other basic linear algebra problems so
eigen values and eigen vectors or for
clustering problems or matrix
Exponential's and heat kernels and it
turns out that you can actually use the
ability to solve applause Ian systems to
solve these problems quite well and it
as well okay so that's one motivation I
guess the other one the one that is more
my Ally is they've emerged is a very
powerful new primitive and algorithmic
graph theory and I'm really not going to
talk about their uses a primitive but
other people here have or will and the
what's happened is that kind of the
asserted convergence at the start of
this lecture in the assertion that you
can use tools from one to speed up the
other has actually gone both ways so
there are these very deep connections
that will exploit in solving with ossian
systems that let us use the graph
theoretic properties to control the
linear algebra to make fast when you're
out for algorithms but it turns out that
you can actually use these connections
the other way and out so you're in use
the graph theory to speed up your linear
algebra but then once you have fast
linear algebra and it's been used
recently to solve a whole bunch of long
standing open barriers to get past
long-standing algorithmic barriers for a
whole bunch of problems so max flow
commodity flow spanning trees sparsa
fine graphs which we've heard about from
the keel so in particular a first
motivating application I guess
the nikhil's first talk which solves a
plasticine systems and the certs that
you need to solve linear sorry that uses
the solution to laplacian systems as far
as I graphs that's what faster if you
can solve for flossing systems quickly
but also a whole bunch of other problems
and Alexander will talk about a bunch of
those tomorrow okay so that's my super
high level vision and the plan for the
lectures is as well so today I'm
actually really going to only barely
talk about laplacian so today my goal
was going to be to present the
background from very standard classical
iterative methods that will be used in
the other lectures so James when I was
but he was a committee of these lectures
kind of he has to make these very
self-contained and so the hope is that
if you have never seen a iterative
solver before that idea today's lecture
you'll be able to see the next lecture
which will use the self applause Ian
systems I'm then going to do in the next
two lectures too so James also said
don't get over-aggressive you don't have
to present a whole laplacian solver and
so i'm not going to pick two of them and
so today is going to be background on
iterative methods number two is going to
be one approach which is the one that
it's I'm going to file an algorithm due
to cuda smeller and hang it loses a
couple of factors from some of
particular day or more recent work but
it's got this very clean simple picture
and i'll say a few words about how to
improve it but it's actually going to be
pretty close to the state of the art and
i will get most of the algorithm in into
the second lecture so i'll skip some
details but give you the high level
picture and it's going to be based on
something i'll describe how it sort of
works which is hot which is recursive
preconditioning and then the third
lecture i will talk about a recent
algorithm that is that i wrote with
Aaron stood for Lorenzo Lorenzo or rakia
and so on zoom which is on kind of how
to avoid the machinery from the first
two lectures so the first two lectures
have developed through classical
iterative methods and show how to use
them to do preconditioned recursive
precondition for laplacian systems and
the third lecture Machamp will avoid all
of it and get an algorithm that actually
doesn't use any recursive
preconditioning at all and that being
said i should say that it has
that I think it's it once we sort of see
all of them they're very strongly
related in some highly illogical note
and a lot of the motivation for what it
does comes from the ones right before it
and so I think what I wanted to do is
sort of present both collections of
methods also because i think that the
methods from each of these general lines
in different ways so the ones from sort
of the second class has recently been
used for max flow problems the one for
the third one i think will be used for
some things and other settings and as a
sort of clean simple and self-contained
algorithm that will let us solve the
posse on systems really fully contained
in one measure ok exactly set up um I
now I'm going to kind of put my apology
in here and the general apology is that
we're doing a miracle analysis and I'm
going to not so a lot of the stuff that
one does with everything i'll do today
it works really cleanly mathematically
if you do everything where you pretend
that you can just do real arithmetic if
you really can't and i think it kind of
hides the ideas if you write the
numerically stable versions of some of
the things i'm going to write in the
first cut so what i'm going to do is I'm
going to write things that are correct
assuming infinite numerical precision
and just because they have the sort of
clean mathematical structure that makes
what's going on actually gonna make
sense and I'll say a couple words but
I'll probably largely brushed under the
rug the right way to implement them so
that you don't do something horribly
wrong and I should say that for each of
the each of the things I talk about
specially for the chebyshev method which
will see today which involves
polynomials there's sort of a right way
and a wrong way to implement it and if
you kind of blindly apply the
polynomials I'm writing down it's very
much the wrong way and it you can write
things that are mathematically
equivalent in the sense that you're
going to be if you pretended you had
infinite precision you'd be computing
exactly the same things but organizing
the computation a way that doesn't
horribly blow up your stability and
turns out that the good ones are
actually quite stable and the bad ones
are very not stable and I'm going to
largely brush it into the rug just sort
of for clarity I'll be happy to answer
questions about it or kind of say what
we're doing wrong but I guess the main
point here was i'm not writing something
that's numerically stable if you ever
implemented you should and numerical
analysis is a field like I'm ignoring it
almost
these lectures but it actually needs to
exist to make these immaterial
algorithms and it actually can be it to
work you know these are not inherently
unstable they're just presentational
unstable okay oh and the other thing is
just in general feel free to feel
questions and drop me cut me off that's
all right okay good so moving right
along I today's lecture is going to I
think really not make it past nineteen
eighty or so but I want to talk about
just for general methods for solving
linear systems so my main goal here is
just to give you kind of the high level
picture of iterative solvers and I guess
the main question r asking is how do you
solve ax equals B and from a CS theory
side I guess we know the answer is that
you can do an o of n to the 2.3 73 time
using appropriate 10 series we're not
going to answer that question where do
instead look at structured linear
systems and ideally sparse ones and you
know kind of the theoretical answer the
answer these I just wanted to convince
yourself algebraically though there's a
solution you know it's kind of multiply
by the inverse of the matrix right in
real life this is very bad right and
there's a couple reasons one is it's of
course quite slow it at best is then to
the 2.3 73 whatever which we're not
going to be able to tolerate if you have
a graph or the trillion vertices also
the real problems are sparse right the
problems that show up a lot if I have in
a trillion vertex crap it's almost never
dense and if you write out the universe
of most sparse matrices you cannot yet
sparse matrices back and if you're just
writing on inverse and multiplying you
don't get to exploit that so you pay for
something that this has no benefit from
varsity also there are these precision
issues that arm acknowledging exists and
then ignoring a better answer sometimes
is I guess gassy illumination which is
the right way to do x inverse or
initiatives at equivalently you know
computing Lu factorization and back
substitute these are not abstractly
always bad ideas right there good if you
have sort of an unstructured problem
that's dense if I give you a dense
matrix that you want to solve all in
your system with and you know nothing
about it that's actually not a terrible
thing to do and
it's also nice in that when you compute
the value factorizations you can solve
multiple linear systems once you want to
hang all your work to get this
factorization you can still you can
solve a bunch of right-hand side very
easily okay so this is not something you
want to universally roll out but it
won't be the goal for the lectures and
the reason is that things we're going to
mainly kind of work towards are going to
be applause Ian system so think graphs
give Laplace seems that are sparse we
want to solve it and much better than
even N squared time right even the time
just break down the whole inverse okay
so um and kind of more generally in
practice very very rarely are problems
Denson I'm structure they tend to almost
never exist and so getting a handle on
how to exploit sparsity and structure is
certainly is going to fundamental goal
okay so for our systems main technique
is iterative methods and so I guess
there's many ways one creative broadly
design iterative methods for this i'm
just going to think of it as anything
that's iterative so the idea is instead
of trying to exactly solve the lit the
zone like ass elimination or Lu you're
in this infinite precision world you're
just exactly solving the system here
think you start with the crude guess and
repeatedly improve it and ideally your
steps will be very cheap both in time
and memory so you don't want to write
down the whole matrix hope like a whole
matrix every step and also you want it
to be very fast and you should think of
it as like each step should be a
constant number of matrix vector
multiplications plus some other left
extensive stuff like some vector
additions and the hope here is that if
you're doing only matrix vector
multiplications per iteration that you
can exploit the sparsity because if you
multiply matrix times vector force
matrices are certainly faster to do that
within dense matrices the other thing
that's going to show up in these is that
if i give you gas elimination and you
know how long it takes has nothing to do
with the matrix right where is if i'm
giving you these iterative methods and
there's some numerical property of the
matrix that strongly get paid to
behavior and it's often in essentially
every case i can think of other than
lecture
a three in the series and things like it
it's going to be dictated by the
eigenvalues and singular values and
arguably vez okay so that's what we'll
talk about today I supposed I see some
people in the crowd might note already
know everything I'm gonna say but I
should apologize to them but ok let me
know kind of give you the high-level
ideas ok so first let me start with some
notation assumptions we're gonna solve
ax equals B and for the rest of today
every matrix I ever write down will be
square and will be the size will be n by
n if I ever say m you should think it's
the number of nonzero entries so for
graphs vertices RN and edges are em all
the matrices will be symmetric and
positive definite and so in particular
nondegenerate now this one I guess
doesn't seem like a it seems like a
photo fairly restrictive constraint but
it's really not that bad right not all
matrices are positive definite not all
the more symmetric but it's really not
the end of the world and the reason is
that you can use a black box solver for
a positive definite symmetric system to
solve all linear systems or at least all
amount to generate ones and just by sort
of a silly little algebraic right if I
want if I can solve symmetric things and
I'll just multiply both sides by a
transpose and I can solve a transpose ax
equals a transpose X so this is not a
horribly generality losing assumption
but it doesn't guess come with some
simple questions first which is that I
motivated this by saying sparsity and I
just you know a transpose a won't be
sparse but note that i don't have in
everything i do i'm only going to be
able need to multiply by the matrix
involved so I'm never going to actually
have to compute a transposition just
have to multiply by it and so the age of
two x EI and then multiply by a
transpose so you can still exploit
varsity ok so other notation ah unless I
say otherwise lambda is always mean
eigenvalues I'll sort them in order so
lambda 1 is the smallest I'm Dan is the
biggest and i'm assuming positive
definite so that's a strict inequality x
star is going to be the exact solution x
i's right oh yes i should address
two chests in solution to this one yes
thank you sorry the right-hand side
should be be otherwise I can get one
really quickly okay so anyway um X star
will be the actual solution X I is going
to be your guest and your iterative
method I'll write e I for the error on
the left hand side so for the difference
between your present guess I'd X I and
the actual act of the actual solution X
star and I'll write our eye for the
right hand side error and so if I'm if
ya is the error in X and our eyes the
error on the right so it's b minus ax I
which is just a times e i- times the I
so now there's a senoia ng sign
convention with this these negative
signs pop up and I think I consistently
kept it in the lectures but give them
even consistently keep the letter B and
that Matt optimistic okay so the other
thing I should say now that won't little
circus later is that there's sort of a
right norm to measure of your error
turns out that measuring your error in
the Justin or the general Norman axio
the Ultraman X isn't really the right
thing to do it because if a has very
widely different I different eigenvalues
and changing X a little bit in one
direction or another direction will make
a growing big varying difference in the
right hand side and so instead the sort
of natural norm to use is the a norm so
if I have a right enormous little a it
just means that instead of taking you
measure enormous by just if whatever is
inside the brackets transpose a whatever
is in the brackets so the a norm of the
I is the AI transpose AE I and that's
going to be the quantity that one really
wants to shrink and most of today it
won't really matter any normal do but
for once we start doing preconditioning
we're gonna have to be careful in this
you did this food yes I should I do yeah
so that's the square of the north thank
you um again anyways so the product of
the left and the right
yes so yeah I guess this should come
with the additional caveat that somehow
this morning I discovered my slides got
that that we mangled by PowerPoint
PowerPoint did not adversely change my
equations but is fixing PowerPoint
adversary changing the order that
everything appeared on the screen
because remember my equations might have
mistakes in them so if so I'm sorry um
okay good so I'll start with our first
iterative method and then we'll see how
to improve it so the first iterative
method where you look at is just great
innocent and that we know so what we're
going to do is we're just going to turn
our latest justum solve into an
optimization problem so our goal is
going to be to minimize f of X where f
of X is going to be our errors mr
squared ok with some consistent ah which
is um right so we're going to take the
error we're going to square it hopefully
and then we're going to use that as our
objective function and then we're just
going to try to improve it by gradient
descent so the idea if we'll compute the
gradient if you do the algebra correctly
yet the radiant is two times ax minus B
which conveniently just equals the
residual x 2 and know that if I make a
symmetric and positive definite as I
have then this thing is a nice convex
function it strictly convex so it has a
unique minimum and that happens when the
gradient equals zero which is just when
ax equals B so all I've done is
rewritten my problem as a minimization
and I just said yeah the error is
clearly never less than zero so when
it's zero worry oh that's our set up and
then a very natural algorithm to have a
first guess of what we'll do is gradient
descent so find the direction of speed
this decrease and just take a step in
that direction this of course comes with
the two obvious questions of what
direction and having a step the first
one brilliant the second one's a little
subtler of how big a step to take
there's a couple choices the right one
is line search which means that what
you'll do is I picked this direction I
have an objective function I'll just
take the whole line and look along the
line for the best answer in this case we
can actually exactly compute the right
step size so if you do the algebra it's
easy enough to figure out the exact
right step size in the things we analyze
we're going to just
we're going to change that a little bit
nobody that won't affect the asymptotics
but we'll make our lives are you okay so
kind of filling through the
instantiation of this the gradient is
just negative 2 r.i and our algorithm is
just going to be you know initialize it
we're going to start with a guess of
zero that's without loss of generality
because you could just replace X with X
is your initial starting value and so
you might as well start with X 20 so our
residuals be and our algorithm is just
going to be repeatedly find the gradient
direction and note the gradient
direction is the residual these are kind
of convenient coincidence or nine
cleanses and then the update staff is
just you take your present value of x
and you add some multiple of this
residual to it I I started you can
compute the best thing to do it's not
very hard it's this thing that will
never use again so this is a fully
formed algorithm for solving linear
systems and it's worth noting that it
does fit my description iterative method
right if you notice all we ever have to
do is write the lines are chance so
these you take the line RI gives you you
know you keep all alpha so it's a line
and you take the one that minimizes the
objective function along the line it's
just the restriction of a quadratic that
a kiss-off far okay so all we ever need
to do is matrix vector multiplications
and vector operations right and the
reason is that you know you're the only
one that could be subtle as the RI at
the stack direction but competing the
gradients just computing RI computing RI
is just computing ax minus B all right
so the gradient does nicely lineup and
so all we ever have to do is I give you
my present value of x you multiply it by
i subtract it from be repeat so what we
have now is actually a well-formed
iterative method we just have to
convince ourselves it doesn't take too
many steps and the nice thing to note is
that's a constant number of matrix
vector multiplies per iteration and so
at least we have some hope with a bit
album okay so now let's see how well it
does
for this I'm going to slightly simplify
it I'm going to analyze that some
essentially first-order Richardson
iteration and all I'm going to do is I'm
not going to do one search I'm just
going to fix one alpha and use it for
all the steps so you're going to choose
alpha in advance as a function of the
matrix and then you're not going to line
search every step you're just going to
use that same alpha over and over and
when we do the analysis we'll see what
the right alpha is now if by the way
worth noting that this is really mainly
to sort of preface the stuff I'll talk
about later it's not that hard to
analyze this even with the line search
but this is one that will generalize a
little more cleanly you can actually
think of the line search as behaving
more or less as if you just it will be
at least as good as the analysis I'm
doing here and in general it will be the
same so if you were to think in kind of
a worst-case asymptotic sense these two
will behave very similarly it is
possible the line search can sometimes
do much better but you should think of
it as just a gradient steepest ascent as
more or less just picking the best alpha
in it without retelling the right
outside advance so okay that's the main
simplification not a huge deal and we're
just going to do some algebra with it so
note that a RI is just alpha RI is just
alpha times b minus ax I um and we're
going to just kind of play with the
equations a little bit and write this as
I minus alpha a I times X I plus alpha B
so this is just a rearrangement of terms
now okay so what we're going to try to
do is convince ourselves as converges
quickly and now we at least have a nice
setup for the iteration and so we're
just going to write out the area this
really is not a super deep analysis but
it will be important as we go forward
okay so here all I'm going to do is the
only thing you could do which is just
write out what happens error and then
hope you can see how it goes down so if
I look at the difference between X I
plus 1 and X star all I did was subtract
X star from both sides I have a formula
it's just the one above it minus X star
and now if we just kind of expand it out
a little bit well just week we'll see we
can rewrite it as follows will note that
B is just alpha a
x Act sorry is a times X so alpha B is
just alpha ax and now the point is that
we can rewrite this as something very
nice we can be rated as this fixed
matrix I minus alpha a times the error
ex my ex I minus X star so what this
tells us is that if we look at the step
that this gradient descent is giving us
we can just rewrite it as multiplying
the error the e sub I by RI minus alpha
and that's convenient because now we
actually can analyze what happens to the
air right so this says this is the main
benefit calculation way of fixing alpha
is that this is now nice and clean so
here we solve is that the error gets
multiplied by this matrix I minus alpha
a and so if I do it a whole bunch of
times i guess x the power of the matrix
and so we end up with the the the error
x.x i minus x star just gets multiplied
by 1 minus alpha a to the eye and in
order for this to be small what has to
happen is that we have to control the
norm of this matrix outfit 1 minus out
they a so um one kamini i get b 1 is the
identity um here good so okay so let's
just see what happens it's not that deep
right you um you want to study what
happens be error so you say matrix times
vector and you'll just downed it's norm
by the North be spectrum of the matrix
times the original starting form right
and so the point here is that if this
thing is substantially less than 1 then
we'll get a fast convergence so this
point i put a generic norm sign because
it doesn't really matter later when we
do things with preconditioning being or
like this will be truly whatever not
want because we're just going to show
something is contractive but starting
later in the lecture the angular is the
right one since this will be true about
whatever you're forgettin also your mom
has to support it that I can come out as
to means norm of e to the power is
that's going to be able to do something
so I said I mean are there any makeup
you are not not a rabbit right you know
the does not will satisfy this
exponentiation some of them on my mouth
right so sorry but I have for our
dispatchers answering whether use the
identity or a matrix not a generic nor
so it's an estimator and here so yeah so
the answer is here you should really
think a norm but I put a general one
because it's good for any major so what
happens we now just have to convince
ourselves at 1 minus alpha a has a
bounded that's one arm and when does
that happen well the key point that's
will emerge over and over is that we
have nice symmetric positive definite
matrices what happens when you analyze
powers of them or any polynomial applied
to a symmetric matrix all you do is take
that pill and we want to fly you to be
like you down okay so here the
eigenvalues one minutes out to a are
just 1 minus alpha times the eigenvalues
and in order for this matrix have found
in spectral norm all we use for all
these to be less than 1 and how much
less than one will dictate how quickly
this thing converges so the right choice
of alpha is going to be the one that's
going to make the worst case of these 1
minus alpha times lambda i's as small as
possible right so if i had a
one-dimensional system I mean well I
could just make alpha be 1 over whatever
the number is you know one over lambda
and then solve it in one step but we
have to do is simultaneously pick one
alpha that simultaneously makes all of
these things small in absolute value and
so upshot is we want to minimize the
maximum value overall I of 1 minus alpha
times lambda I what's the right thing to
do it's too well it's it's either going
to be the biggest one of the smallest
one that causes the extremal value so I
want to just pick the Alpha that
minimizes the max of these two numbers
of the biggest eigen value of the
smallest eigen value and the answer to
that is you make them equal and it's
going to be given by two over there is x
1 over their average ok so now giving
you write alpha and we can just plug it
in and get the right analysis right so
now that we know what the right outfit
is we get the right value for this
maximum
which is just 1 minus 2 lambda 1 over
lambda 1 plus lambda n that's just
plugging into the equations and when we
put it together what do we get we get
that this maximal value is going to
equal well we can rewrite it a little
bit we're going to divide we're going to
divide the numerator denominator by
lambda 1 and write this as 1 minus 2
over 1 plus this ratio lambda n / 121
and we're now from here on em going to
name the ratio lambda n over lambda 1
kappa and that's going to be the
condition number of our matrix and
that's what's going to dictate the
convergence of essentially everything we
study so the upside of all this analysis
was that we gotta the max value of this
function was just 1 minus essentially
constant over kappa and so the number of
iterations that it took was something
that depended linearly on Kappa right so
if I want to make one minus alpha high
small I want to make it less than some
epsilon and asking what do I have to
raise this thing to to get it to be less
than Epsilon and so what is that well
it's like think of this is just one
minus one over kappa you know so you
raise it to the kappa pal you get a
constant and then raise it to a live one
over epsilon yet whatever constant you
want so what this tells you is that in
particular this algorithm actually does
have an analyzable bound and it's not a
terrible it says that once we put this
all together if I correctly choose my
outside can get this to converge in
number of iterations that grows linearly
with Kappa with the condition number of
the matrix and so the main takeaway
points are that this works and that the
important parameter that dictated the
numerical properties was the ratio of
the biggest smallest eigen values and
that really should make sense in that in
the sense that like if that ratio were
infinity if you had a zero then we hope
we'd expect things to go horribly awry
right if the smallest eigenvalue we're
actually equal to 0 then we really
should have stuff blow up in horrible
ways if they're pretty close to each
other we're more or less trying to
invoke the identity which would work
pretty well and somehow the things
shouldn't depend on X understand
volcania scale give it to because we're
not ever nothing changes if I just
double the whole Bank board okay so
that's the first descent
and we're going to try to improve on
that any questions is easily used ok
don't ever use this as a user can use
this the first step for multi-language
just glued in this person so ok yes so
it's on it shouldn't be you're already
there are times I guess it's not that
easy to use it partially but we're going
to improve on it steadily substantially
more the nice thing is it simple and
certainly it will think the green sent
burger that will be used a fair amount
when you're not solving linear systems
by doing many other things that you
don't have to be visible structure but
yes I guess sometimes as a partial
sketch I'm about to improve it than I to
substantially so it's at least easy it's
a nice thing about it oh ok so now what
so before I actually talks about how to
improve it I want to talk about another
way of writing this whole algorithm down
that I kind of want to argue that we
already knew how to do this and my
assertion is really what i just said for
you was that applying matrix apply if i
give you a symmetric matrix you just
pretend it's its eigenvalues and so if i
want to approximately compute one over x
by a polynomial i'll just use a Taylor
series so I claim that I a minute so
this next slide is just going to be my
intention of exploration i'm going to
say they're really all we did was write
down the Taylor series and why is that
well if you expand out their occurrence
you get XK is something it's a
polynomial in the matrix applied to the
vector B and the residual is something
else never call it will apply to be and
this is just by induction so now let's
just going to forget what the polynomial
is and just note that what we've done is
we've said X hey is this polynomial that
we wrote down a plugged apply to the
starting vector B where the polynomial
is this thing and what is this thing
that I just write down all I did replace
the capital A with a lion colony
I polynomial this is just the Taylor
series 4 1 over Y around wondering of
that so if you expand out the algorithm
that we just did you take steepest
ascent any fix the step size you end up
with your whole algorithm really was you
want to morally you want to compute one
over a so you're going to write it to
Taylor series so the first k terms and
apply that to your right hand side now
why really expand it around something
other than one or around wherever we did
the point was is that again we're not
applying this simultaneously to all the
IV down right like we want to send its
kind of trouble cover all the directions
simultaneously for a 1 by 1 matrix they
could tell our stand around a single any
value and get rate of convergence that
is just immediate but you know we have
to sort of simultaneously get this
polynomial the Taylor series to work it
all the eigenvalues so we're going to
put alpha and a square in the center um
you know 1 over alpha square in the
center and the Taylor's banking on that
so to write this out a little pedantic
Lee we're going to say nothing depends
on the basis that we work with so we
might as well just look at the eigen
basis and then we can just pretend
everything we ever write down this
diagonal i'm going to write things for 2
by 2 matrices just because there's
nothing the changes just think lambda 1
and 2 or get an X and the system we're
not trying to solve is that lambda 1
lambda 2 times X is b1 b2 of course
remembering it we don't know how to
compute the eigen basis or else there
would of course be easier algorithms but
you know analytically this is what we're
looking at if you're ready yayuh basis
and then the actual answer X star is
just what do you want to do you want to
do 1 over lambda 1 comes B 1 and 1 over
lambda 2 times b2 but you want to get
this by applying a polynomial for the
whole matrix and so all we're really
doing here is saying let's take the
polynomial one of the function 1 over
lambda and we're just going to apply
this polynomial which is the Taylor
series of other bricks we're going to
apply that at the matrix will
simultaneously a Bible the eigenvalues
and then what's the error term the error
term is just the error of the Taylor
series right it's going to be what's
left over when I take the different
between the tail
series on Mount Olympus things are not
so it's not unreasonable to you have
more interviews o Jerusalem to give the
stupid yes actually that's a very good
which is that if you weren't able to
really understood your matrix then you
could certainly do much better right you
can pick a polynomial that's kind of
handcrafted and what I won't really talk
about but it is true is that if you use
a public on via gradient method it will
actually have an error analysis that
will really say you'll perform as well
is the best polynomial that you could
use to interpret guiding values and then
um which will give the government set
but what's nice about conjugate gradient
and I'll say a few words in it but not
really is that math and manages to
performance well is that that's
polynomial without instance a friend who
no matter if they're all behind in
values what I'm to talk about next slide
is just a better source of to me our
polynomials that only still relying in
an axe but you could of course open
expecting at a benefit if the eigen
values or cluster these on this way
other questions ok so now so i asserted
that we're going to do better than this
and the question is how how can we hope
to do better than you know better than
the territories and so we need to first
just a tractor book and I kind of
already sent the approach i just
described was applied polynomial matrix
so let's just write it only using
polynomials and so and this is really
just to see what we're going to do
moving forward is find better
polynomials than the Taylor series and
i'm just going to write out what we're
doing so that we see what the properties
are that we're trying to get so okay so
what do we really do we really just
picked some polynomial degree K that
I'll call PKA we applied it to be and
remember that B is just negative a times
the optimal answer because X satisfies
ax equals B or if negative yeah okay so
writing this out more what do we get we
get that our error EK EK dr after k
iterations is just we showed that what
it was you're just taking
the polynomial well writing it out right
you just plug in the polynomial time to
name to the X subtract off maybe the
next are and see what happens and when
you end up with it as you end up with
that your error is what you get by I
minus the polynomial here it was the
taylor series applied to your matrix
sorry i plug and then that whole thing
applying to your to the vector X star
and I'm just going to name this whole
this quantity of 1 minus y pa why I'm
just going to call that Q a lie or qky
for each one of the other words so the
upshot was that you know all we really
did was apply polynomial to our matrix
and then what that into the actual error
was apply a similar problem another
polynomial to the air and what the error
was was we wanted pfk equal one over Y
and so the error we got was just the
difference between y times are alleged 1
over Y and one right so the we got so
this is just exactly what happened on
the tailor's Harry aside we want this
move on y PK to be 1 because we want a
PK to be PK I want to be 1 over Y
instead we got something else and then
what happened here was that we took this
error polynomial and apply it to or we
can later okay so and here note that our
original error was actually X star so we
end up with an actual relative error
bound so now we can say what do we need
to do to do better we need to get
polynomials that make good things happen
with cute right the operator norm of
this matrix qk bay is just the max over
all the I over all the eigenvalues of
the polynomial qk applying Blanton's
wait sweetie played out it's that and
then what we get in our previous step
was we just use a very natural way to
approximate a polynomial that if i say i
give you a peridot niall you want to
local your prep i give you a function
you want to locally approximated by a
polynomial the standard first thing when
we do is just read up a telescope that i
want to actually want to so pretend
Athens one I want to approximate 1 over
X I'll write it as you know 1 plus x
plus x squared plus X cubed plus that so
forth right so that's all i get is just
a Taylor series and um
okay so now the question is can we
really do better ah ok one more
construction once I wrote that out what
did we get as our error we then just
multiplied if you just take your
polynomial and multi idea the next term
the sale of Taylor series is your error
that's exactly this one minus alpha by
of decay which was the thing that gave
us our that we needed out kappa
iterations right so we're Taylor
expanding around this alpha in the
middle your polynomial was then 1 minus
silver of 10 / kappa and you have to
raise it to that power to get something
good any questions ok so now the main
point is that we actually don't nothing
that we did required anything about that
polynomial could be like to be the
Taylor series and all we really needed
was well any polynomial P we wanted it
to be to make this expression small and
it's going to be a little easier to
construct a queue so note that if I give
you any Q the only can you know it comes
from a p as long as I can do that so
it's just every polynomial with first
term one right so every polynomial with
two of 0 equals 1 is the key
corresponding something and so what are
the properties we need well first we
need to know we can still implement this
and the point here is that we can write
if I give you any polynomial in the
matrix a applied to a vector B then
there's certainly a way to do this which
is just I write the coefficients of the
polynomial P out and then to compute
each monomial I just take the previous
monomial and multiply it by a well
actually see that there's a recurrence
relation that's a little faster so turns
out we won't likely he doesn't even a
little better than that we can actually
just keep the last two terms and science
5 free chocolate cards but from an
algorithmic just sort of an asymptotic
standpoint all we need to know here is
that we can compute this with matrix
vector multiplies by just computing the
monomials and then each time we compute
it my know me only added times of
coefficient to the previous one okay um
so what I'm going to show you in the
next couple slides is something that if
you haven't seen it before i think is
kind of
prize which is that the Taylor series is
the wrong way to approximate a
polynomial in this case I'm in many
cases and so what we're going to show is
how to construct a polynomial qk of life
that's vastly better in its asymptotic
so it's going to be a polynomial that
instead of being instead of being one
minus one over kappa it's going to be 1
minus 1 over root so it's going to say
that you can get the behavior of using
the first case k terms of the power
steering I've go Taylor series but
you're only gonna use square root of K
terms in the actual expansion so the
that's going to mean that if we can
implement this will end up with is that
instead it will get to take a square
root of aeration which is a big deal
right like it says that however many
iterations were taking before we're
taking rough with the square root so
will the kind of square root of Kappa
and set a cap yeah degree of you cave of
the case its simplicity always I'm sorry
so if you can use the cape and whatever
series of right now sorry I guess the
Little Miss Kay's and Papas i'm not sure
if they look too similar cap is the
condition number caves the power yes so
qk is the case comp and so we're going
to show here is how to get the degree K
a degree k polynomial that is much
better infidelity so all we need to take
the green room type I instead of narubu
kappa and sort of kappa so it's the
square reason finish remember is that
its
questions so you're a traditional
service linear and the only increase the
debate but one invoice yeah so the
variations in the simple separate issue
there is just going to be yeah you're
just going to multiply in one matrix
vector multiply and some additions to
then compute to it yeah and so it takes
UK snaps to make a degree polynomial
take a iterations and think each
iteration is usual think sparse matrices
to think of matrix vector multiply is
like one of your kind and so you should
think that the number of iterations it
times n is about how long it will take
it in those bases and so you want to
keep the other nation countdown but you
know they want to look square matrices
for items that you would it's possible
right exactly so you don't want to do
dense operation right so you're not
going to ever compute the whole you
never to compute you know the actual
polynomial holomatrix a because that
would completely destroy your varsity
you're going to get it by taking some
you taking your starting after just
applying the matrix repeatedly which is
if you would get as far as matrixes i'm
going to have no it's going to only be
begin hearing the number
non zero ok so now how are we going to
check these polynomials so I guess the
first question is why would you even
think that these exist you know I guess
and so I'm going to just say out loud a
couple things about where this might
come from and then depending on how long
I drone on about that i'll say I'll bury
how much I said about them but ok so the
first question you might ask feels like
why if the talent show is not just the
answer like if you take a intro calculus
class you wanted the right way to
approximate the function by polynomial
is the Taylor series um my assertion is
that that's not really true and the
reason is that the Taylor series is sort
of an optimal point for one specific
question the taylor series says you're
looking in this infinitesimal
neighborhood around your starting point
and you want to be as good as possible
in this infinitesimal main road now here
we don't have that situation what we
happened we have this range of
eigenvalues lambda 1 through m 2 and
that we want to be good on and we really
don't care they don't just care about
infant s labor we want to be good for
this whole sort of finite size region
and we're going to see is that the right
thing to do this is going to be my very
crude schematic is dirty dance about
okay um let's see it back the so you
know what we'll see is that kind of
morally if I want to approximate some
function here i'll make my function
what's so it's a good pic to the drop so
if i want to approximate let's even just
a shower function be you know if we want
to approximate our function locally it
right around the origin then the Taylor
series gonna do something like this it's
going to be very it's going to be kind
of locally correct but i'll probably go
believe they bring and what the writer
thing to do is if i tell you that you
want to be correct in some finite region
then what you're going to do is you're
going to tune your actual approximation
to the region that you want to be
correct over and what it will do is
instead of kind of greedily making the
starting point work it will oscillate
around the function right it will be a
function that will be 2 into the region
it'll probably go horribly awry the
second you leave the region but will be
tuned to the finite immediate value
approximate okay so that's my very crude
answer it's that we want to
approximately over a finite region not
an infant a small region so you think
that the choice of polynomials it
depends on the region the slightly more
informative one is that what we'll see
you that we're really going to write
down is essentially going to say use for
each fourier series not taylor series so
if you think about kind of a caricature
level I the two things we know how to
approximate a function maybe the ADA our
first cutter for Ian Taylor series you
know Fourier series are sort of shooting
for a finite region and they're vastly
better behaved if I give you a
polynomial or any function on the circle
and I want to get a good approximation
of the function on the circle then we
know these via these very strong
convergence counties you get for doing
before a vaccination which is supposed
to look like my little squiggle whereas
if you try to do Taylor series you get
much much worse things for periodic
functions and so what we'll see is that
in some sense all the stuff i'm going to
right now and really is just the real
part of a fourier series and that's
where these things come from but they
sub X oh ok that's my handwriting answer
now let's actually do it so what are the
properties we want we want it to be so
we're going to shoot for Q instead of P
just cause it's a little easier to
construct but you should think what
we're going to bum we're really doing is
constructing a basis for functions that
are good at approximating stuff on
finite regions so and then we're going
to see what they do ok so the
construction will shoot for here is that
want a polynomial that's one at zero and
we want it to be as small as we can
inside our region lambda 1 to lambda n
so now my kind of squiggly caricature is
going to become that we want our
function to be we're forced to have it
you want to 0 and then I give you this
range lambda 1 plan to end we want it to
be as small as possible so I guess
Taylor series do something like this and
what we're going to end up doing is
going to
something a little bit more like this um
so that'll be our goal and we're going
to base our construction on chebyshev
polynomials so let me tell you the
properties will use about chebyshev
polynomials use them to get the answer
and then tell you what they are so it
checks a pound on those the properties
we're going to use our just that it's
going to be nicely bounded between
negative 1 so the actual problem of
wheels are you they're just going to
basically shift this interval to
negative 1 1 and so trevor's upon of
those have one property which is that
they're very nice and well behaved
inside negative 11 and they blow up very
strongly once you leave negative 11 so
they if I look inside negative 11
they're bounded by negative 1 to 1 and
then if I give you anything to the red
the interval day so if i give you a type
5 into 1 plus a for any positive a they
blow up exponentially ok so the case one
looks like 1 plus root something that's
like root out every day it doesn't
matter the two and then raised to the
cape town so they shoot up it's going to
be very quickly and they turn out to be
optimal for a property like this so then
once I have these all we're going to do
is just kind of shuffle things around to
make the negative 1 to 1 become this and
make the often fun infinity become this
right so we're gonna try to make the
value of zero be very big and the value
in our interval be very small some
people removing the official good ah
this is very good this is very easy you
have to normalize them someone they are
optimally anything
for fishing right I what's missing from
you I did I forget to write at their one
hook that they're also how the way you
like them a thing to do we go through
the stupid yeah so on right now only
writing data chebyshev polynomial i'm
not that they're not going to be about
this is the bottom you'll actually use
and then the leading coefficient is
going to get invited out because i'm
gonna i'm gonna transform that i might
think i wrote something that's still
none i think i was like it's that that's
not back to us negus maybe own today you
are dumb be one right so all i did just
yet
cause the very logical
is it somehow it is here
so that's a very good question that's
the Sun sets the motivation behind my
i'm brushing oracle shoes under the rug
apology at the beginning so the real
answer is that yes the chebyshev
polynomial that were down they have
horribly the coefficients that explode
and that actually causes very bad
numerical issues of what you do is write
your chebyshev polynomial as a
polynomial and then multiply an ad that
was essentially the content of biology
at the beginning but but instead we'll
see when we write down the property
field a of preterm recurrence relation
and so the right thing to do is
essentially to use the preterm
accomplished and also tie it back to the
residual so then the right numerical a
to compute them is to write a couple of
the things that I'm equivalent that are
mathematically for going to bothering
the right hand side and the common owe
me along the value in the correct way
that you don't lose for this stuff the
troops off to infinity and that's why if
you look in the American analysis book
the innovative method of describing is
in the look a bit different is that
there's a way to write it we're only
using the sort of last couple term
update and you're essentially
referencing it back to what the actual
value in polynomial is supposed to be so
that your marriage they should also
infinity so on the gradient descent side
of things would correspond to instead of
just instead of if you want to drive
Taylor series for once excess rentals
etc what you do is instead of calling
the the mondo meal instead of getting
that by multiplying by the matrix a
whole bunch of times or the use b minus
ax as a way to type tie it you're going
to do the gradient descent when you tie
it back to the actual right hand side
they usually schedule instead of public
and you can do the ability here so yeah
that's why there's a capacity these
coefficients do carburetor thanks um
okay so once we have axes we're going to
do we're just going to sort of a shift
and translated so I'll the final in your
map that's just going to this is the
lambda 1 and lambda n and all I'm going
to do is just kind of flip it around so
there's linear map here is the thing
chosen so that it maps negative thats
lambda n 2 negative 1 Maps lambda 1 to 1
and then it back 02 whatever
for us to map 02 and the point is that
we're going to hope that when we do that
is if there is a big gap here compared
to the scale here this will have time to
blow up and get very big at zero and
then if we so that's what this linear
map does that gives us a polynomial that
is hopefully much bigger at zero than it
is in the interval and then we're going
to scale it down so instead of being big
and small it's one and small right so
the numerator here is just take your
championship polynomial and that finally
change it to map that they itemize the
interval and then we're just going to
divide a nice value of zero to make it
be one and small as opposed to there's
two numbers that are far apart so that
would be our construction and so I claim
that when we cover my animations YouTube
horribly right now something installing
um okay so let me figure out what's
going on the computer um I think that I
just did my computer's being slow so
nice Korean Alex on me that's our plan
camp is not responding wait area okay so
yeah let me just keep them so it doesn't
break so okay so the point was that
anything that has the properties have
asserted and being that it's artists i
gave you the ice is breaking so badly
okay so this is really not good um okay
so it's gonna have the property I
starting that easy to verify if i can
get to my previous slide I will show
them to you oh they're gonna from Mecca
shot here okay so um the the point is
dressed that I look at this what's
actually happening it's um yeah so
inside the interval I now that giving
you the slot enough times like a secret
was kind of look at it if so for lambda
in the right range it's mapping the
interval here and then this blown-up
property is making the thumb zero much
bigger so if you're going to look at qky
we get that it's you know we get that
the denominator is going to be pretty
big in the neighbor Italy pretty small
and we get exactly 23 asserted okay so
this was easy the harder part was
getting the polynomials that actually do
it fitness right so any questions other
than whether i should have publicly bash
microsoft giving back path lots of
friends who work day Oh yep so did you
that's a bill just yes that's another
good question so the conjugate gradient
method which is not what I'm doing
manages to get away with not knowing
them and performance so if I told you
those then this would perform it then
conjugate gradient didn't tell you the
cosmic radiance would perform as well as
a mess colony meal so it might as well
know them here or what I'm doing
requires you to in advance to know them
the reason I'm doing is that later
conjugate gradients is not going to be
it's going to lack certain properties
that will need for new medical precision
next lecture and so we want to fix
polynomial and we bill in lowland you're
just in velocity in case actually have a
study flying in limbo on them there and
pour these [ __ ] in the loop yes so
actually yeah so for both this you need
to know downsell into one right man um
okay so capture Cardinals so there's a
couple definitions of them and I'm there
right three of them and then gesture at
them to say why they have the proper you
so the one I think is the most intuitive
one is the trigonometric one and when
you should be thinking here it is really
we're doing for analysis but I saw they
check on under a finger variables so the
definition i think is the cleanest to
work with in the lot of these cases is
think of TK is the polynomial for which
the following hold and I should know
this is not obviously a polynomial so
well if you look at it you'll say so
you'll say i look at cosine of k theta
and then i'm going to assert that that's
a polynomial in cosine theta and the
chebyshev polynomial is the polynomial
we've got property so it's the
polynomial such that this hold so it's
cosine is cool yeah I can't believe our
plan for that kind so it's cosine of the
face k there r cosine of X and it's not
obvious as a polynomial but it is
obvious that it's nice right because if
you look at what we're really doing is
for a series under the change of
variables where we just take a cosine
okay so why is this a polynomial well
the easy Toyota verifies polynomial is
to note that
sign is going to obey the following
recurrence and then pretend that it
defined polynomials or the recordings
and they're the same thing so definition
to is the following or membership
polynomials when I assert that they're
very easy verification that they match
my previous assertion right so I'll
define 2012 13 x + TK because regards to
next ck x minus contain ended one thanks
ok so it's just a double and going to
deliver the version that was came k plus
1 is to verify that it obeys use
recurrences and then it now convinced
ourselves that is it off and now once we
have both of these there's an even nicer
one to work with for one of the bounds
and that's going to be an explicit for
Portland you're taking you could have
just written down from scratch setting
it's a little motivated which is this so
it's just the right way to convert one
to the other is if you write cosine
theta as e to the I theta plus e to the
negative i theta over few and then just
plug it into the first one it's not very
hard to get this expression ok that's
what we'll you just to verify the
balance of the second and okay so those
are our three versions of Java shut
problem deals because I'm running so I
will not crowd along too much about with
pain but I think they're anything but I
will convince you that they're true and
satisfied the properties we need to get
ago so what those are the properties i
thought i said that they supposed to
have their supposed to be small between
negative 11 and they're supposed to be
being when you leave each other okay so
I plan these your immediate from the
appropriate choice of these three
choices and definition so properly wanna
claim is immediate from the
trigonometric definition right I want it
to be between negative 1 and 1 when x is
between negative 1 and 1 but note that
when x is between negative 1 and 1 r
cosine makes sense and i'm taking cosine
of something and so that something is
going to have a cosine that is the pre-
only one because it's revealed okay so
that one was trivial and that was why i
might as well as a tiny things that was
the more or less what this is if they
slightly
transformed cosine and so that's the
sniffles in the number of times it turns
around will be the up to a plus or minus
one will be the degree of dollars and
okay so property one that stays down it
inside the region is Ed and then
property to the blowing up one is been
satisfied then the follow immediately
from the explicit formula right so if
you just ignore in the second term
that's what's it for most certainly
mounted below like this and then note
what was the point here the foot was
well if i plug in something bigger than
one ah you know then I'll get something
i'll get at least one here and then i'll
get something that's well bigger than 0
and i'll raise to a high power so if we
stand it out when we get me get TK of 1
plus a and it's just i just plugged it
into a formula and then if you just kind
of write out what's inside there you get
1 plus a and then you get to out to a to
a plus i square and then you're just
going to ignore bunch of charlie's kick
oh that was like that is ok and t and
maybe and she'll be the same letter this
is a deprecating notation of us we're
writing your confidence um okay so
thanks good so I'm right anybody up top
as you just start racing terms and
keeping the one and you end up with a
fairly easy as I recruited you don't
know me that's not a normalized
to be morning and then you won't be no
matter free so that is the best and
infinity of oxidation 0 function
autonomously brand and then it goes like
people denied escape and that then is
that's a good way understood by exactly
this is the because this is precisely
the right so this is a yes sir I just to
restate that vm the property I wrote
down was a scaling of the assertion guys
so if I scale this down or I would get
that assertion and you could just ask me
out you want to get as good at el
affinity of exactly just that the reason
I can recognize I didn't know a very
short proof that these are the
polynomial that you get that I other
than going through route interpolation
stuff like I didn't know a bunch already
can take that and can construct other
side polynomial so it was neither to
verify that they are right once you get
some I didn't know that way that didn't
feel bad if you do some context loyalty
are you sure just because they meet
their 3.2 was having subsidize sports
tributary right that is most of you to
poop and it's a proof that they are
optimal once you get them it takes a
little bit more actually thought about
throwing up in but the reason I cut it
is that I couldn't think of a motivated
way to guess them without yes but that's
yes about the assertion that actually
there is a principled way of deriving
what the right answer here is which is
that we're putting some infinitely many
linear constraints on a polynomial we
have a constrained optimization problem
will find best pilot Emile to be one and
big and act in the interval and small
and another place doesn't want to be
small and you could just bend right down
this infant and fill out being insolvent
and then its way to verify the
is actually optimal for the construction
we're getting here once you have them
and it says that sexually the property
you want is that I had something that
oscillates and want all of these extrema
to you want have as many extreme as your
time as their degree can tolerate you
want them to be as small as possible and
then you can actually see that that's
just the existence of the cool
certificate for the optimization problem
yeah probably if I had Miguel me I'm
going home already have it so versus let
me finish up this and then i'll be happy
to give the enemy love fun happy to get
to a longer version of that ok so the
upshot of all this was that we have
another promise result which was given a
condition number oh we can actually
solve them in systems when something
that depends on in the square root so
given any linear system we have a simple
iterative method that you can get to
error epsilon in the limits like root
kappa times a lot whenever epsilon
matrix vector multiplies the square root
savings will be something we'll use next
lecture we do with boss seems to
actually get the right runtime if you
want found it gets a little worse if you
don't if you you won't get something fun
is good if you just try to use the let
me know if you didn't at describing
their um know that it gave a priori
bounds of your serene and as I'm through
promise there is an algorithm conjugate
gradient that will perform as well as
the best polynomial it more or less is
just taking us out of orthogonal
polynomials in the appropriate norm it's
a little harder to use and I don't know
how to get the numerical analysis for
the recursive preconditioning to go
through for it and so the nice thing
about chebyshev is a fixed polynomial
which means that you can control the
errors in a different way you can take
advantage of the fact that two fixed
polynomial so that the conjugate
gradient will any impact pacific world
or performance as well and again you
know to me it's worth noting is that
yeah when you have clustered eigenvalues
there are polynomials that do better the
thing right arrows
well answer for only assuming a biggest
and smallest found if I have myself a
straight somewhere and I doesn't worry
about the structure you can certainly
get polynomials that are small battle
over better using that structure then
the last thing I'm going to say and
we'll talk about it in depth next
lecture is that this is not always next
it's a function of Kappa and we cap it
bad this is Terry very slow when things
are no conditioned and unfortunately
laplacian circle conditioned so my final
assertion of the day is going to be the
Colossians are often ill conditioned and
the easiest way to see that is going to
be the path de Graaff so if I give you a
path we I think would you know it's um
the ratio of its biggest and smallest
eigen values is actually going to be any
sway a number of overseas squaring and
so that was it will be here is square
root of n squared so n iterations to
solve LOL awesome system in half graph
and so that's certainly won't give us
all in your tongue out and so in some
sense what you can interpret a lot of
the other stuff that's going to come
later is going to be something that's
going to be our only in front and if you
want to take a couple hundred pages of
recursive preconditioning and reduce it
to a paragraph i think the paragraph i
want to say is that if you really take
care of paths everything else is fine
and that the two algorithms will present
will be two very different ways of
taking care of paths so next lecture we
talked about how to do with recursive
bringing the shape and electra after
we're gonna talk about how to do it with
the sort of building a different basis
for the face of functions in your
working life okay so back so it
concludes my background so starting next
lecture i'll actually give you things
that were in the last 40 years and so
next lecture i'll do is talk about the
algorithm
smeller Kang that will give you a
natural almost fully proven on slides
modulo Magna building to type letters
proven goals of a new litter solver then
after that we'll get one that doesn't
need any different condition all right
questions yeah oh so the reason with
that the M what we were going to set the
fact that we're really shooting for with
a polynomial that with 180 and smaller
commander one of them to end and so we
napped negative 1 in 12 Randall fafsa
the biggest I think maybe I'll take
other questions offline just cuz I think
I've run a little over or not the answer
any question